massive thank you everyone for coming
and making uh the effort as Maria said I
know there's tube strikes been absolute
chaos I know people have come from
Manchester so thank you for making the
effort you absolute Legends
um I guess I also want to say like these
events would not be possible without
companies like PGC but also Salisbury
convince Sherry they've been long-time
podcast Partners so if you still have
not spoken to these companies like you
need to
um just to frame up how we're going to
do this
the first sort of 15-20 minutes we're
going to talk about this year what we
learned biggest challenges what we've
taken away then we're going to talk a
bit about next year what have people got
top of mind and then we'll have a solid
amount of time for live q a as well
because I know when you come to these
events if you don't feel like we don't
talk about the things you want to that
can be annoying so
um Matt and my colleagues and I run over
microphone and if there's any questions
that you have for the panelists then
we'll make sure they can answer them
um but let's welcome on and give a big
hand for our planners today Claire Ben
and Harry
all right
are you feeling all right there's a lot
of people here ready to go all right you
got your microphone mate you might be
sitting on it I think you're selling it
got it yeah awesome
um should we get straight into it
okay so let's do a really short intro uh
Ben I'm gonna come to you first my
friend if you could just for those that
don't know who you are give us a short
intro then Claire you next uh and hurry
often and we'll get straight into it
thanks uh my name's been brought on the
Grandad of the group this evening
um I've been in recruitment for just
over 23 years started with S3 to six
years there then I was managing director
of Premier group 15 years I joined that
business 12 people took it to 130 across
UK US
um exited in February last year saw my
shares and basically launched premise uh
14 months ago we've gone from zero to
Now 37 heads five million quid Revenue
across UK and U.S that's me Happy Days
thanks
Claire hi
um so I've been recruitment for about 15
years which I think how many recruitment
is like dog years isn't it isn't it I
say we're about 150.
um so I started a fade done spent 11
years there started with about 20 people
left around 800.
um
oh no
I think we can still hear you allowed
enough I reckon GG can you help us out
hello hello there you go there you go
swap
um let's out in the states start up our
office in San Francisco I lived in New
York then left after about 11 years took
some time out and then launched storm
three so Storm 3 is part of 11 group I
launched in Feb last year so in 18
months Storm 3 has gone from zero to
160. people four offices globally soon
to be five eleven groups come from North
600 in three years so yeah yeah it's
pretty intense
um I reckon actually that's a good intro
that's good that's good that's good all
right Harry last but not least my friend
well it's gonna be really it's pretty
tough now
um I'm Harry Thornton I run sales for
Rama Solutions uh we established a
business in 2016. we focus on helping
early stage Venture Capital backed
software organization scale go-to Market
teams across the US and Europe I joined
the business when we were six months old
we've scaled the business to about 55
people across the U.S in Emir
um
and we're here to build and scale the
great business within the ecosystem that
we're currently operating in awesome
mate well thank you for uh being up here
so I guess let's just dive straight in
so Ben I'm gonna come to you first sorry
it's just working yeah yeah it's all
good so let's just start with and this
is the one of the only few questions I
sort of sent to you guys beforehand but
like what has been your biggest lesson
learning from this year let's just start
the conversation now
um I've got two okay but they're both
shorts it's fine uh for me I think this
applies to whether you're a consultant
or a director or an owner of a business
taking time out to properly like step
back and review your business this year
for us has just been [ __ ] insane
um and for me like the biggest lesson is
just you get so in depth and just your
heads in the trenches so much the time
planning down time at your diary to
properly step back and have a look at
your business and strategically review
what you're doing is so super important
the second one is just product and
solution selling which for us has been
massive so for us packaging rolls up not
just looking at the ones and twos in
terms of delivery but looking at
properly taking 20 rolls 30 rolls for a
client and really doing a nice wrap
around offering obviously a disc account
but making sure you're adding extra
value to the client on top of just
normal contingency recruitment has been
fantastic for us because we've locked up
a load of clients exclusive business and
it's just been been really kind of
beneficial for our business in terms of
growth nice yeah I'm definitely going to
ask you about that productization piece
as well Harry over to what's been your
biggest lesson this year I think I'll
probably speak for everyone here 2021
was a great year for everyone in
recruitment I think everyone probably
had a great start to this year and I
think there's obviously been some
changes throughout this year in terms of
where businesses are pivoting technology
Etc I think the biggest learn for us was
that you've got to con keep a scalable
process in terms of what you do don't
pivot do not change the process the
scalable process that you follow because
the market changes we are still more
than ever qualifying the candidates to
clients in terms of the markets we work
in and that shouldn't change because the
market does and I honestly believe that
you know that to the start of next year
or the rest of this year is going to be
tough and without the right scalable
process and sticking to that I think
it's going to be really tough for for
everyone in the market to just basically
like really stick and true to no no you
know what works and stay in trees that
despite maybe the market encouraging to
do something else absolutely
okay Claire she stole my ones okay no
I'm joking biggest lesson this year no
I'm joking um I actually agree your
first one just to expanding that I
completely agree and I I found that
really hard that the take like the
zooming out is that the term free yeah
yeah but I found it really hard to think
especially
if you're if you grow up as a recruiter
and you're recruiting you often feel if
you're not selling if you're not on the
phone to a candidate or a client or or
doing core recruitment activity then
you're not doing anything I found that
really hard
um as I started managing of you know you
have those days where you're actually
focused on strategy and you think I've
actually done anything today and I think
yeah I definitely I felt that but it's
so so important
um but I think the biggest the biggest
one for me and we were speaking about
this earlier is
I obviously started recruitment in the
getting the get on the phone days get
out and meet people days yeah right
um
and then it all turned into LinkedIn
messaging and sending emails and there's
obviously loads of good platforms that
you can use now but I think what I've
learned this year is especially post
pandemic nothing beats meeting people
going for coffee
networking getting on the phone I think
it's so easy to we kind of lost that a
little bit for a few years and I've
learned that it's so important to to go
back to that and actually whilst a lot
of people say how it is AI going to take
over recruiters actually going the other
way and going back to what we
what we grew up on some of the junior
recruits are struggling because they
don't know they don't know what phone is
exactly but they don't you know going
back to to get in front of people
face-to-face building relationships like
that's that's what recruitment is right
exactly yeah so I think that's been my
biggest lesson because we
we were not great at that for a while
then we pivoted and now teaching people
tales and it's it's working well you
highlight 500 grads and we'll start on
the same day so I'm not [ __ ]
surprised that's a challenge
um so talking to the challenges Harry
I'm going to come to you let's also get
your biggest challenge this year that
you faced individually as a team as a
business what what comes out for you in
terms of biggest challenge this year
yeah I think I'll talk about the company
in terms of what I think we saw as the
biggest struggle this year and it was
the shift within technology okay okay
and last year covid e-commerce retail
was absolutely flying so anything
digital related was was booming and I
think throughout this year we've seen a
shift within the market of what is and
isn't booming and we are you know
started to really focus around the data
ecosystem right data is absolutely going
through the roof right now the same with
cyber security so we've changed in town
terms of the pivot in terms of which
Technologies are taking off and what you
know where they're going with the
business and you know over time we've
seen that shift and I think you know
going forward we're going to be you know
focusing on those certain areas of
Technology given that you know the need
for it you know where wherever where the
Market's going right now so what so the
challenge was well I think the challenge
is is the fact of you know the market is
let's just say it was very digital heavy
for the last 12 months though those
Industries or technologies have now
slowed down so realizing the markets
that you double down on one absolutely
you've got to be more technology-led
than anything right now in the market in
terms of where you know in a downturn
there's always going to be another area
of Technology that's going to outperform
other areas yeah and that's I think what
we've seen is pivoting the business to
certain areas of where there's the
biggest growth right now okay cool well
let's just let's just talk about that
for a sec yeah I think we can all relate
to that right now from the conversations
I'm having just on that what have you
learned in terms of like what have ended
up being like the indicators or the
things that you start like pick up on on
when you start realizing oh actually
this is starting to slow down or maybe
the markets that we have always focused
on are starting to yeah not be as
fruitful what what did you find to be
the sort of key indicators that started
to give you that information coming back
to data is there anything that you
really notice but yeah I think there's a
there's a few areas I think firstly is
being really close to your clients to
understand what's happening in their
businesses right where are the where's
the demand is PG still top of funnel
right are they still closing deals where
is it slowing down how has their
quarters been and the closer you are to
those businesses the more you understand
and you can also you know you can all
it's like a lead indicator of what's
coming next quarter based on their
performance companies in Ecom start to
slow down let's be honest next quarter
they may slow down on their hiring so
you've got to start to think okay cool
that business isn't doing well for
whatever reasons Which business is right
now are booming right cyber security is
always going to Boom given the market
that we're in right companies are
hitting you know huge numbers every
quarter every month they are naturally
going to grow and continue to grow so we
have made you know we're gonna
I guess spend as much time as we can
with those clients that we're seeing
that shift in terms of the market okay
nice yeah thank you Claire I'm gonna
come to you what what's been your
biggest challenge this year do you think
it's a challenge for us so we've only
been around for 18 months right so the
recruiters
they joined in a bull market it was
brilliant and they joined what do you
mean by that like to make it simple when
everyone was hiring everyone's hiring
technologists we work in health Tech
right so that's again a massive area
that's that boomed since the pandemic
and they didn't
we well I set up the business basically
a talent of the pandemic so he didn't
have to go through the recruiters have
never gone through a financial crisis
covid it was and then the market got a
bit tricky probably July August for the
first time I've never seen it before and
I think that was probably the hardest
bit of for me I was like it's going to
be fine of course it's going to be fine
recruitment is always fine technology is
always fine you come out the other end
companies make layoffs so what that
means is Talent you know you but you see
recession everywhere and everyone's
making layoffs and obviously they're
like oh God this is and I think for me
that was hard of just keeping
even in believing that genuinely just
keep everything's going to be fine we
don't need to Pivot we don't need to
change just give it a couple of months
like and there's still money to be made
let the other recruiters slow down we
will just go harder right and I think
that was hard
um because again they just didn't have
that experience to be able to reference
hold on during covid the group recruits
made a shitload of money I think that
was hard because I think they felt
hard thing about being a leader in sales
is you're good at selling right so like
stop selling to me I'm not it's going to
be fine I think for me that was that was
hard and obviously we're out that now
it's like a couple of months where a few
clients went on hiring freeze I think
that yeah what do you think about that
now because I'm the conversation I've
been having is it that's continued
a lot more challenging than maybe it has
been
yeah but I don't know maybe I view in a
different way I started my career during
the financial crisis in a financial
recruitment firm you know procurement is
not fun if everyone's hiring and
everyone needs Talent like yeah so
you've got but you obviously you've got
way more evidence to point out as to
like I know it's going to be fine
exactly but that no I'm hearing this a
lot because it's like how do you help
people build that self-confidence when
they've got they haven't got that
evidence to go oh yeah no it may take
three months to sign up just got upskill
you've got to find okay well let's find
the clients that are hiring let's head
on from the ones that aren't you've just
got to start
I'm really good at recruitment and I
think that was hard of you know my
really good recruiters did well but the
ones that were okay and had done well in
in a great Market that's when we started
realizing right we've got a upskill okay
that makes sense no that does Ben
biggest challenge
um Lee's William also from Claire's
point which is for me we when we
launched the business
um obviously I've got 24 years of
recruitment so I brought a load of
clients with me which was great after
your covenants though right obviously
yeah yeah sure is there a lawyer in the
room
this might go watch
and we basically had an amazing delivery
business right and in the back of my
head I was losing sleep when I going
what about when the market changes what
about the market changes so you know it
was constantly in the thought of my head
that we you know we had Farmers rather
than hunters in the business so we just
we invested in training around 360 going
out and hunting new business and and
making sure you're a full 360 recruiter
which luckily is now paying dividends if
anything we left it a little bit too
late
um but I think now the skills to be able
to go out and Hunt new business is the
most vital skill in recruitment right
now
um so if you don't have that skill watch
a few of your podcasts maybe absolutely
yeah and upskill so so basically just to
clarify that because this is definitely
what's been coming through from the
conversations I've been having so you
felt like you maybe doubled down or had
too many people in your business that
were only willing to do delivery or were
only good at that totally yeah we have
we have a delivery function in the
business we have a 360 team
um but just just my personal opinion
I've never seen a market like we had
right for the last couple of years like
it's been the best I've ever seen it
um and now it is definitely slowing down
do you still have that delivery function
we do yeah because we still have a lot
of delivery based clients that still
need um people but for me you know I
think making sure that you're Skilling
yourself in the art of Business
Development is the most important skill
you can build right now so that brings
in quite nicely on to like that that was
definitely from looking all the
questions that came through that was
definitely a popular one about the
current market advice for people to
Harry let me come to you on this one I
know in terms of URL from what
understand sales director so you will be
looking at the sales strategy how can
you get more out of your existing
clients how can you get new logos in in
the business
um so I guess the question I have for
all three of you but I'll come to First
how it is like for this this year war
has continued to be like your most
successful Channel approach whatever we
can go as Grand as you want when it
comes to consistently winning great
clients and great business Waters
continue to work for you and your your
team this year
yeah good question I think there's two
main areas that we're seeing right now
um the first is when we when we started
the business in 2016 we went on
several growth Journeys with high growth
organizations effectively right we hired
20 30 40 50 people for certain
organizations which naturally the VCS
that were back in the organization's
heard about us right because the quicker
they hire great people
the more money they potentially make and
the quicker they may then get an exit so
once you do that with two or three
companies in a portfolio the VCS are
start starting to be interested in your
business okay great where else in the
portfolio could you potentially help us
and we've been very fortunate that we
have a list of you know five or six
great tier one VCS that help us in
plugging us into some of the most you
know successful startups right now in
the industry so they'll typically
introduce us to a pre-series A or series
a organization and we'll work with the
founders to help build and scale their
go-to Market teams off the US that's
such a great Insight I know that's
something that we spoke about in your
podcast there's like a genuine strategy
that so getting because if you imagine
if how many more Journeys you go how
many more companies you go on that
Journey with but just on that so what
does that actually look like is it that
you build that reputation and they
literally refer you to people are you
giving them a kickback like what like
what's in it for them besides if they if
you enable them to hire great people
then it makes their investment even more
stronger because they might actually be
able to deliver on what it is that
they're planning on I'm doing but is it
just straight introductions what does
that actually look like I think firstly
it's [ __ ] tough and once you get to
that point where they're willing to put
there we do similar and we make it sound
so simple playing that doing it that way
with the VC route
now but if you get it right which you
guys clearly are but like what what's
harder than like getting to the point
where they trust you building that
reputation but for sure right is having
that trust of you're a good partner
right because at the end of the day a VC
will own 70 80 of the business when the
business exits the founders will earn 10
or 15 they have a bigger share in the
business typically than a Founder will
right so they have more say quite a lot
of the time of where the strategy
recruitment of that business comes from
um it takes a lot of work and by no
means have we completed it and we've got
a long way to go in terms of developing
those relationships but no there's no
Kickbacks I'm not sure that's legal
um
um but um no the what's in it for them
is is really you know the the investment
of hiring great people that help them
towards an exit much quicker yeah so
they want to hire the right people for
the right job to help scale that
business in the right ways and also the
expertise of you know knowing how to
build a U.S business and then help land
them into Europe Etc not a lot of firms
have the exposure to both the US and a
mere Market from Landing them into the
European market okay nice yeah I mean as
well let's make let's remember the
biggest problem a lot of the companies
we work with have is the talent piece
right and you guys will know this when
you recruit for your own business that
is up there with the biggest challenges
so if you can help them solve that
that's that's huge so you said there was
a second one what was the second one the
second one is
um utilizing your champions
to help you
go into other organizations or introduce
you to other organizations that for us
is massive a champion is someone that
trusts you believes in you that has your
back that will help take you to the
right decision maker within an
organization
to make that introduction that you know
I've used Harry Harry's great at what he
does or Rama's great Harry's team's
great you want to speak to them they've
hired 20 30 40 people for me over the
last few years you should have that
conversation all you need is a warm
introduction to help break that
because you know these guys are getting
hit up hundreds of times a day
and it's really tough if you're going in
completely cold do you think you can
only have Champions if you actually like
place them or build a team for them or
do you feel like you can build Champions
by just delivering an absolutely
outstanding experience but maybe not
getting
the person that they needed or the team
that they needed I think you can okay I
think it's really tough yeah because
that person doesn't know how you operate
because you may have not worked with
them or you may have not hired people
for them so you've got to build a level
of respect maybe that is you have a
champion that introduce you to another
person and that guy naturally becomes a
champion because he knows someone you
know
um but it's really tough without
delivering for them and working for them
previously
just curious quickly how many of your
Champions are internal recruiters
zero
so I wasn't sure how that would play out
zero correct okay cool all right
um Claire I'm gonna come to you best
like what has really worked for you guys
yeah winning new business similar I
think you know BD's BD right there's we
all do the the same stuff right and I
think I agree on the VC front I think
it's a really
smart way to do it and it's interesting
now a lot of the VCS have their own
Talent teams right
um but they also want your help because
they can't manage it no no some of the
best best VCS in the world have three or
four people and they've got a thousand
companies in their portfolio definitely
so that's an interesting one I think
I'll answer in a slightly different way
I think
we do a lot of Business Development
obviously we didn't exist 18 months ago
and I think what's really helped us
grow and have a really good name in in
the market is being really focused on
what our Market is so storm three we
only work with startups and scale ups
and health Tech so Health tech companies
disrupting health so like mental health
Tech Telehealth femtech
I'm really strict on what we don't do we
don't do big Pharma we don't do biotech
we don't do anything clinical Medical
there's so many clients that we have
where half of their roles we couldn't
work and we could make money from but we
don't touch that we only do engineering
data product sales
and I think that really helps like
knowing what you do is is important as a
recruiter or as a recruitment firm but
knowing what you don't do and saying
what you don't do and not trying to just
do everything because there's so much
other you could do everything and I
think that's really helped because it
means
we're just getting deeper and deeper and
deeper and therefore going wider into a
market rather than just going oh let's
just do everything else so answer it in
a slightly different way obviously
there's lots of different techniques
that we use like
same same probably answers to you guys
but I think it's
really staying true to the markets as
well we're not trying to diversify too
soon even though there could be money
there options yeah nice then obviously
as you said delivery function obstacle
in people 360 what what things are
really working for you guys I think for
BD purposes speaking to the business
owners in the room when I launched
premise we built an LED board who were
all not ex recruiters or recruitment
LEDs but industry LEDs so we've got a
guy who's uh CTO for SpaceX and X prize
on our board and having like industry
leaders on your board who can Champion
you to the to the market is has been
invaluable for us I think from a
consultant level so I've launched in the
US twice now and every time we've done
it we've done Round Table dinners drinks
events cto's heads of talent
um so if you're a consultant or a team
leader of Team Management business get a
budget doesn't have to be massive two
grand get all your clients in the room
build relationships build networks and
the the value from that is just for me
personally invaluable so if my team ever
comes from like can we have a budget to
run an event these are the people coming
go and do it because that will just paid
evidence just to make that clear for
everyone like how does that actually
benefit BD besides getting these types
of people in the same room is it it just
equips your team with a reason to call
people it's yes it's a it's a reason to
call but it's also you can't build a
better relationship face to face and
it's and you know I think that that's
what's in in a tough Market that's what
pays off relationships clients that come
back to you because you have a personal
relationship with them
um and for me you know there's also an
argument of building automation into
your business I think that's a
completely separate topic but I think
the personal relationship and getting in
front of people massive dividends for
your business
Okay cool so let's move this on a bit
then so I had
um a question just to sort of round like
this year off and we may come back to it
but
um a question from Cherry Swain and that
question was Ben I'm going to come to
you if I if I may and that was what was
the most impactful thing you did for the
success of your business in 2022
one thing launch us
um for us it's you know it's it's our
main Revenue generator
um average invoice 28k everyone finishes
in two weeks so there's no three month
notice periods to wait for people pay on
time it's just the best business if you
can get it go and get it right yeah
we're gonna get onto that
um we're going to talk about that Harry
one thing that you the team business did
that you think uh really created success
for your business in 2022
think it's going to be invest in l d
most important thing invest in best
practices invest in your team invest in
your leaders invest in if you can
upskill your leaders to the best way
possible they can help upskill their
team as well so I think we really
focused on upskilling our leaders
putting them through the best l d
programs we could
upskilling your l d people as well to
ensure that everyone has the right best
practices we can always stick to them
throughout doing this job love it Claire
one thing
keeping it fun keeping it fun it must be
fun the amount of people yeah you know
like we it gets tough for recruitment
sometimes again it got a bit tough when
the market got a bit sticky and it's
just like
one day I just went into the office
let's just make it fun again you know
and I think how'd you make it fun
just like celebrate little wins
recruitment can be fun if you make it
fun be in the office like we're in the
office nearly all the time and I think
it's so easy like
to just sit behind your computer at home
like that's not fun get in the office
um yeah celebrate some more wins be
around your colleagues
it's it's simple stuff but I think it's
really important to remember
enjoy the journey enjoy the journey the
journey is the reward yeah
that's it awesome so let we like when we
get into questions feel free to ask
these guys anything about this year but
let's just move it on to for me
personally I've done about
um you guys it may not be relevant for
everyone but for me I've definitely seen
a trend in companies like yours Ben
yours Harry and yours Claire in terms of
um
um in being in the UK but recruiting the
US I think that's definitely been a
trend that I've definitely picked up on
on scene
um so I guess these were this is just I
guess just paint a bit of a picture for
all of you I got this uh these stats
from PGC and I guess it just puts it
into a bit of context but I think what
they shared with us so a bit to what Ben
was saying in terms of what they see in
terms of the UK um average fees anywhere
in terms of what they agree anywhere
between 15 and 25
um in the UK but in the US Ben you could
you guys can shed some light on this but
what PGC finders it can be anywhere
between 25 maybe even up to 40 terms
agreed and
um seeing obviously deals between of 50k
dollars and above but also I think this
is also crazy obviously the UK
recruitment Market is competitive
um and I think what the way that they
painted this was there are more
recruitment agencies in the UK than
there are in the US obviously let's just
think how big the [ __ ] us is and uh
the UK doesn't even fit in Texas
so yeah that's like a crazy Insight
right so I guess let's just pick this
off so how I'm going to come to you how
long just get pen is a bit of a picture
how long
um has the US Journey been where like
give us a bit of a timeline in terms of
when did you start maybe doing us
business and yeah how long have you been
doing it firstly yeah so we we started
doing us business right from the start
um
we were just lucky enough that some of
our clients needed help in the US and
they needed help in Europe right so we
naturally just did that
um we are very heavily focused on the US
65 to 70 depending on the quarter in
terms of U.S business
um we launched the US business in
January
um and the most important investment
again is you know it's generally as in
what do you mean in terms of the
underground boots on the ground physical
location office in Texas
um okay so that was January this year
you did January this year we still did
business to about eight or nine people
um we invested again l d in the US we've
got sales leadership from the uh the UK
um moving over to the the us to help
build and scale that out
um so we were quite lucky that we always
had a lot of business in the US right
but for us it's about being on the
ground going to meet these clients
Jumping On a Plane two hours not 10
hours 12 hours whatever it may be going
to meet candidates like we're in Austin
Texas right it's one of the biggest Tech
hubs there is right now in the US and
it's about that investment of people and
time in that region that we've seen the
most success right now yeah so I've
definitely let me just hit you with this
question then so this is um a question
from Alex Hutchins which is basically
just talking to what you said yeah so
the question is and um you guys feel
free to share this because I know Claire
you just opened the New York office Ben
you've got an office in New York Boston
right so the the question from Alex is I
don't know Alex they're based in in the
UK but did the US so he said in the
North American Tech Market where 99 of
vacancies are remote what is the main
benefit then of moving your UK
recruitment team to the us when you're
factoring the associated increase in
Staffing and Taxation costs
don't know what you're gonna add to that
like I think personally it goes back to
the point of earlier's relationships I
think you know once you're getting those
initial relationships face to face being
around the corner from a client let me
pop around and see you grab a coffee
that's how that initial relationship is
built
um and don't worry you can definitely
recruit the us from the UK like you
definitely can but for me if you want to
scale and properly grow us business you
have to have boots on the ground I also
think it's it feels it seems similar UK
to the states I lived out there for five
years I remember when I opened our
office in San Francisco realizing okay
we kind of sound the same kind of not
really but
is so different there's so many nuances
they do you know and even in the
different states people do business in
different ways the laws are completely
different in different states let alone
in in the US there is so many
there's a lot to understand that you
think you kind of understand if you're
here but you don't 401ks the schooling
system even
you know Healthcare yeah it's just a
completely different base and you've got
to be there to get it to understand it
and American grads are different the
types of profiles you hire a different I
think you just got to be there and to
get it properly right and I think you
can't be an naive and just hope ship a
couple of your British recruiters out
there and it's going to work like you do
have to keep updating they change the
laws all the time don't know
um so let me ask you this then Claire
what works in the UK that doesn't work
in the US
being rude to people
[Laughter]
um what
what look in the UK everyone knows what
recruitment is right come out of uni
people know what recruitment is they've
got friends and recruitment brothers and
recruitment it's an industry out there
they're like are going to the American
accent but give it a go if you want
hey you don't you don't have to you
don't have these don't do it
um but they you know we advertise um as
like sales Business Development it's
different people don't really get what
it is and my boyfriend's American I've
been with him seven years and he's like
right so candidates they pay you to find
them jobs I'm like no that's that's not
what we do
um it's it's just not
head hunting maybe is a thing but again
it's no one knows what it is so I think
it's you have to really that's different
is hiring grads tough because you've got
to explain to them what on Earth we do
and even when they join
sometimes they still don't quite get it
for a while okay uh Ben let me come to
you then principles to like what would
you say from your journey so far what
would you say are some of the key
principles to gaining Traction in the US
moving over there or doing it from the
YouTube just just as a whole like if you
look over the last 14 months what do you
think you've done well that's enabled
you to to gain traction yeah I think in
these places I think with anything pick
a niche pick a pick a you know pick an
area yeah don't say I'm going to recruit
for the US I'm going to do you know a
full stack developers like you've got to
pick an area and really go for it
um understand the market understand the
laws of that market build your candidate
base
um and get in front of the clients I
think is the most simple thing
um it is still recruitment it is still
black and white you know in terms of
what you need to do on a day-to-day
basis
um but as Claire said you know every
single state you're in is completely
different so pick one get to know it get
to understand it fly over have a holiday
over there get on Sunday for it and then
just just make sure you own it so just
on that um this is part of Alex's
question then we'll move it on he did
also say like so if you are moving to
the US what factors should you consider
when deciding what state to set up in
the most common ones I've seen are the
ones where you guys are Austin Texas
um New York also Miami it seems like as
well but tamper is now one that's coming
up and a lot of companies what what like
why do you do why do you choose I think
as a business owner it's it you're
looking at the markets and where the
revenues are I think as a consultant if
you're looking to move over to the US I
think you need to look at your lifestyle
like New York is London on crack like
you have to be able to deal with that
and and love that life London on crack
yeah that's New York really yeah amazing
yeah
um I'm too old for that now by the way
this is for this for you
um but you know Austin very chilled very
nice Good Vibes I think for you if
you're a consultant like you need to go
and visit these places like go and soak
up and experience it from a business
point of view you need to if you're a
business owner you need to be looking at
where you can get good talent good
talent you know you look at where the
universities are you're looking at you
know New York for example is super
expensive in terms of salaries
um whereas your Austin's your dialysis
your tampers much more cost effective in
terms of getting good people in the door
okay Harry B obviously you've been doing
it for a while obviously have quite a
few people there now what what's been
your biggest challenge since expanding
in the in the US do you think or really
given that like since January what's
been some of the biggest challenges
specific around the USPS
I think firstly it's hiring the right
people yeah really tough I think the
cultural difference between the UK and
the US is huge and I don't think anyone
knows how big that is until you actually
go and launch an office there um I think
the biggest challenge for us is we
didn't have sales leadership on the
ground early enough right right so
you're trying to manage the US business
you know you have l d That's great right
but that's not sales leadership and for
us to manage sales leadership from the
UK for you know the last six months is
really bloody tough so I think that's
been the the you know the biggest
struggle we've had the guys over in the
U.S spend a lot of time over here in
Europe to really bleed the the you know
the culture of the office and how we
operate and what we do and the processes
and everything that we put in place okay
because without that it's really tough
nice
well let's let's move this on to how you
guys are thinking about 2023 and then
we'll go to um audience questions so I
guess firstly obviously Claire were
talking earlier like
yeah I'm definitely having conversation
with people like people a lot of people
enter the recruitment show in the last
two years
so that is like you said their
experiences of working in recruitment
are going to be very different to like
what we've experienced over the 10 15.
but like how how would you like how are
you currently feeling about your current
market at the moment going into 2023
let's just start there
yeah good I think
we've all learned a lot of lessons
probably in the last six months of where
we need to upskill and where we need to
to train and how we need to Pivot we
need to make sure people can do business
development properly and adapt so I
think
with all of those lessons going into
next year is just getting better and
better again no it's never going to be
what it was I don't think well maybe it
will be but it wasn't saying right 18
months ago or so but I think it's only
going to get stronger from here so yeah
feeling positive we're opening an office
our office in New York we've got one in
Dallas now but we're going big big on
the states
um we're pretty much a US business just
happened to be HQ in London so next year
is all about that so exciting Ben how
are you feeling about
I'm very confident we have amazing
people for me this next one let's just
invest in my people train retain look
after them make sure they've got solid
career plans and just upscale as Claire
said just as much investment in training
um as we possibly can because it's a
shift in market right and so you when
there's a shifting Market you have to
upskill and train your guys and invest
in them uh so for me that's the most
important thing for the next 12 months
cool all right Harry I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask you instead like what what are you
um sorry you don't care about my answer
huh no I'm joking but
um what are you doubling down on next
year and why
great question
um what are we doubling down on I think
there is a shift in the market so I
think naturally companies may say okay
cool maybe we're going to slow down on
the hiring because of the shift in the
market maybe the market the market isn't
as buoying as it was for us we're going
hard on the hiring hiring senior people
hiring graduates because the market is
going to bounce back and it's going to
come back in my opinion stronger than
ever so for us it's investing in new
people scaling the business keep going
on the hiring keep investing in the
business
so then when that market shift comes
back we're ready ready yeah clearly
doubling down on such a good question
I'm trying to think what are we dropping
down on
um
I mean we always double down on Talent
right we're always hiring more people
like we'll continue to keep how did you
do that by the way because when I say
that on LinkedIn people at once
um like literally how many how many
people do you have start on one day
what's been the most amount of people
25. oh four is more
when they got to reception because we
realized they'd be quite overwhelmed so
they turned up at different times can I
just ask you which probably people are
thinking if you can be honest with us
yeah how many are [ __ ] still there
because like let's just be real that is
absolute chaos
absolutely like generally what do you
reckon we don't look I generally I'm
saying this like we don't just do it for
we don't play it for the numbers game
that's just so naive I've done this for
a too long I'm not going to hire 25
people in the hope that yeah a certain
amount work out right we're really
really strict on our hiring and have a
pretty hardcore hiring process so
within my my brand I think was probably
about 30 attrition okay which is not bad
and you know the people graduate
recruitment people are always going to
leave because no one knows what
recruitment is when they're getting
intimate they don't really know how
[ __ ] hard it is and
what I would say in my team no one's
left to go to another recruitment firm
so they've gone and maybe they've had
you made them hate recruits maybe I'll
put them off that much yeah but you know
I I think for what are you doing to us
Claire I don't know
um yeah look of course people leave
that's that's natural but
I appreciate you sharing that yeah
because that must be crazy uh crazy it
is fun but it's just it's hard work for
you would you you're a bit too old
joking
um cool I get Claire let me ask you this
then because you were talking about this
so
uh what advice would you give the
recruiters here who may have only known
record-breaking quarters which we always
read and saw on LinkedIn for a good
amount of time
um and they've been used to getting a
lot of yeses in the last two years but
yeah going into what could be a lot more
of a challenge Market might already be
there over the next three six months
like what what is your advice for those
sorts of people in the room and the
people that will listen to his back
Bryce embrace the challenges
and
a bit boring if it was easy the whole
time right I think you've got to look at
the challenges if you get an objection
you've got to look at all right how can
I get around that I think it is pretty
simple advice but I think
every you know everyone's smart I get
into recruitment because they want to
learn
you just got to
yeah take a positive look at at those
challenges and think okay well how can I
learn how can I be better or how can I
do something differently or and just ask
for help really simple ask for help
um
sorry is that useful sorry
um
Ben this was a question from Leo Oates
what do you think will make 2022
different to 2023 in recruitment
2023 difference 22. yeah yeah yeah
um I think a shift to the market I think
um it's not going to be on a plate for
you anymore but I mean I was I was
talking to a girl in our London office
today uh president Jess and she said you
know if this gets harder you know what
we're gonna do I said and you made twice
what the Prime Minister earned this year
right and she was like no I didn't I was
like you did like you made twice the
Prime Minister earns and I mean Emma
would be a great prime minister I don't
think she's quite ready for it but you
know this is still an industry where you
can make a [ __ ] ton of cash at like
24.25
um so just embrace it like you can still
make [ __ ] great money and have a
great career and enjoy yourself it's
going to be a little bit harder but
personally I just I love BD like I
[ __ ] love it I don't know why I'm
sick
um but I I enjoy that part of it like
it's one of the most exciting parts so
just enjoy the BD Journey all right yeah
right so I've got a couple of questions
that some of you submitted and then
um Matt if you could help me out with a
microphone in a second
um and if any of you have a questions
put your hands up and Matt will run
around with a microphone
so a couple of questions to kick this
off so how I'm going to ask you this I'm
not sure exactly how your your business
operates but this question was from uh
Khalifa and the question is is the 360
model extinct
absolutely not absolutely not absolutely
not okay
um
I think you need
a few different types of models in a
business to have a successful model not
every skill set is a 360 skill set some
people are great at 270. their skill set
is not hunting new business but they're
great at [ __ ] expanding a company or
a client now some people are just great
at delivery and you can make lots of
money doing that so absolutely not and
if anyone's a 360 I'm hiring so give me
a shout
um but but yeah no absolutely not it's
and I think it's one of the best roles
there is if if that's what you want to
do but it depends okay really on the
skill set Ben Clarion your thoughts on
that is is the 360 model extinct no I
don't think it is but I do agree I think
certainly when I started in recruitment
it was just 360 all your [ __ ] that was
sorry no no no I didn't say that but
people used to say right that was the
mindset of the industry totally changed
the time right of that was the only way
to do it and even if you're really good
at resourcing but you struggle with your
BD well you're not good enough right and
I think it's really changed now I do
think 360 is brilliant but it said it's
an appreciation for some people are
brilliant at 270 I'm glad you did the
math sir 270 or 180 what's the other one
90. yeah 19 90. I haven't heard that
before
let's get down to it [ __ ] is 90. it's
one of the it's a quarter of course it's
a quarter of three things all right so
what are you doing I don't know I don't
know what to do is just speak to people
and then don't send the CVS yeah maybe
not 90. but yeah I don't know what 90 is
I just wasn't trying to get my brain
working but
um yeah I think it's all about us as
owners recognizing
people have different skill sets and
that's fine everyone's different and I
think you need to play to their
strengths if some people are brilliant
360 then then let them do 360. if some
people do a brilliant delivery we have
some incredible delivery concerns in our
business who just nail it
um I do think there is there's some
really good examples of U.S businesses
right now that are doing the 180 model
and they are flying literally flying
um I think you need to be a certain size
of business in order to cope with that I
think you can't be like 10 or 15 people
and have a 180 business but I think
there's definitely a model for it where
it does work really well it's a very
American model isn't it 180 yeah right
Claire I'm definitely going to come to
this question uh this question was from
Drew when hiring grads which you do a
[ __ ] load of
um what are the non-negotiable behaviors
you look for
in the ground
you said your hiring process is pretty
pretty hot mate yeah
we've got to have worked during uni
that's you have to work during your
night that's that's a bit of a
non-negotiable for me they've had to or
or at some point whether it's
in a restaurant in a shop you know with
higher graduates it's red flags for me
and I apologize if anyone didn't work
when they were you know I did I had a
paper around when I was like 11. I don't
know what my parents were thinking
sending me on a paper round at 11 years
old but
in Bromley as well but
it's it's I think it's important that
work ethic of it could be and it could
be
you know doing your parents gardening
getting paid like a tender for it just
some kind of work ethic I think
um for me that that's a bit of an on
negotiable I always ask if I had a
part-time job at Uni
um
that's one for me anyone else like any
non-negotiables that you always look for
I think for me it's down on
characteristics of an individual right
if you're hiring a graduate they may not
have experience to the Working World
so it's really tough to make that higher
based on that person so you have to make
the hire based on characteristics yeah
for me the most important thing or the
most important two things are Obsession
and character okay
lastly you would do intelligence but
more importantly you've got IQ and EQ
okay but emotional intelligence is the
most important thing you don't need to
be super super book smart but if you've
got a level of great EQ obsessiveness
and you've got a great top like this
industry is pretty [ __ ] tough so
you've got to be tough and if you have
those three things I strongly believe
you can you can be great at this
industry what's an example of a crowd
being obsessed with something well it's
great I think you would you would have
to look back at their
personal life right okay so whether it's
something they played Sports to a high
level they're a captain of a rugby team
or a football team or they excelled in
something right you know I think you
have to pick up these things and by the
way it's not Bloody easy to find that in
an interview process but also you can
see how they demonstrate themselves in
an interview are they obsessed do they
really want this [ __ ] job or they're
just speaking to five or six different
people
um so it's tough but it once you get it
you'll be able to sort of understand how
to get it out someone cool right final
question for me and then if any of you
have questions put your hand up and then
that will come to you but this question
is from Oliver Perry Ben I'm going to
come to you love this question
um of what is the most important thing
you can teach a trainee recruiter in
their first four weeks
do you teach them anything
life skills
um
first four weeks
um most important thing
a good [ __ ] Boolean search
um
hence Source breaker in the back of the
room yeah that will help if you're not
using it plug
um I think for me in our first four
weeks it's looking at attitude
um and I think you know it's it's how
they're interacting with people being
part of the team you know getting
involved in training
um that's what we assess people under
the first weeks is look at their
attitudes so I think just come in with a
positive attitude a willingness to learn
uh soaking up like a sponge as much as
you can and if you're doing that kind of
stuff then you should hopefully set
yourself on the right Journey nice
Claire what what do you guys look for or
like yeah what's the most important
things you're really trying to get
through to
obviously there's so many different
things you can teach in the first four
weeks I think for me it's it's the
mindset of don't take it first don't
take rejection personally that's a good
one you know and they'll get their first
nose on day one day two and it's making
sure you're reminding this is normal and
I know it's not always a no
is not always a no no sometimes a yes
yeah some situations where I know isn't
it okay absolutely
you have to be careful I did say that to
my team once and they're like really
they're like I said and I was there no
no yes no is yes no no you can't say
that
um but no I think it's all about that is
is is teach recruit you're not taking it
personally recruitment's all about
rejection and that's going to happen at
every single point of your career
um we make it sound like it's easy on
winning all these clients the amount of
clients that reject us and you know I
think it's so it's about
remembering that because we tell them
that in the interview but then you come
in on your first day you get told no
you're going to get disheartened so I
think it's yeah fine that's okay love
that
well let's do some questions from the
audience is who's going to put their
hand up Matt right yes right perfect
Matt go to whoever you're drawn to mate
that's fair right matches spot okay
do you wanna do you want to stand up
just so we can see your your wonderful
face
hiya how you doing hi hi Michelle hello
um I just want to ask the question about
Business Leaders who may tend to be of a
certain age and how they are finding
managing people who are younger and how
you understand how gen Z are motivated
versus back in the day I feel like this
is aimed at me by the way I'm gonna put
this out there
well having started recruitment in 1997
when there was no LinkedIn no
smartphones no emails life was really
different because when we walked out of
the office it might be late but that was
it it was done whereas now it's 24 7. so
how are you motivating gen Z when
they're motivated really differently and
they've got things that are important to
them that potentially we wouldn't even
be aware of so yeah when you're working
with grads and the the younger
generation how are you doing that
yeah I mean I'm well I'm 35 and I so
that's not gen Z is it well it's
definitely not gen Z no no and I I so I
am older than the grads we hire and I
think it's funny because when we do lots
of incentives and when they first
started I kept doing about um incentives
with Amazon vouchers and I was thinking
brilliant Amazon vouchers it's like 200
quid and after a few weeks I couldn't
figure out why I was no one excited
about it and so I was they're like okay
we don't
we don't we don't use Amazon I'm like
what and I went on my Amazon and things
I bought and it was like bulk buying
Hoover bags
and then I realized and then one of the
guys at work heated incentive and he was
incentivizing them with gardening
equipment I'm like George he loves
gardening bars at the crabs so I think
we really quickly learn ask them what
motivates them and the amount of escape
room things I'm not really a skate rumor
but there's so many different things you
can do I just realized I need to ask
them what what incentives do you want
what are you excited about because I
realized yeah what
give us like top one two most common
what did you learn from that by actually
asking people but then they are
incentivized to win because they
actually want to win whatever that was
like common things that came up a lot
from certain teams that they would
really like loads of social stuff I
think we I've got to remember as well
the you know a lot of the grads are
hired
coming to work was the first kind of
experience that well they'd been at home
for you know two years of our uni right
so
um we do so many social things but it's
not just going to the pub it's a must
it's yeah it's
yeah Escape rooms everyone's fighting
about you said that on me
um Escape rooms immersive experiences
the love stuff like that just activities
and they were so we never had any of
this as when I was younger the amount of
fun things to do but yeah my lesson was
maybe just ask them what they want Ben
and finad have you found
um I'm 42.
um I'm an alcoholic
um no
um for me I mean first of all I've got a
really good management team underneath
me who are younger so that massively
helps me
um I I got back on the tools this year
uh Bill 40K thanks
um and just because it had to be
relevant like I didn't want to be there
like who's this [ __ ] old get to
imagine recruit like I get an idea so I
did that and then we [ __ ] love a
pulse survey just there's like a poll
server every week uh like what do you
guys want to do like what incentives do
you want nice not everyone wants to go
on the piss like some people don't want
to go get smashed some people want to I
know it's crazy right but some people
don't want to do that yeah
um so yeah as Claire said absolutely the
same like cater for everyone and do
different incentives based on what other
people want and just like listen just
like ask them what they want and then
make a change and make a difference but
just listen to them awesome who who else
has a question Michelle great question
I'm not over here mate
nice
I'll stand up hey mate I'm Alex by the
way I work for exp Talent who are the
best rhetoric in London Wow Come on
selfless plug [ __ ] hell put some
money behind the bar Jesus Christ okay
so my question is so it was mainly
declare
but wait put the microphone by mouth oh
it was mainly declared but it was I'm
happy to go to you know the rest of the
audience so some of the stuff Claire
said is a lot of stuff I believe in
which is get on the phone work hard have
fun right now what in my opinion not a
lot of people do is make cold calls
anymore
it's a lot of emailing a lot of speccing
out CVS all that sort of stuff so as a
modern day recruiter what would your
structure of a cold call be oh wow to
the rest of the audience
wait so what's the question what's her
how would you structure a cold call in
the more like a client to a chemistry no
no I'm not no you're recording it I'll
be the client
but yeah that's the question right exp
Talent
mate sit down bro come on right so first
is a small is this been recorded yeah
yeah it is okay right
small tip would be
I know you shouldn't really do this but
always
I used to this when I was hands on I
would always email on like bank holidays
or public holidays because you get out
of office and then you get there mobile
phone okay so small tip
um so you see yeah do that all the time
then I just collect their phone numbers
so
I think keep it short and sweet
um get to the point I say this to my
team I don't think anything changes we
get you know when you get cold called
from whoever when you called me and I
thought you're an estate agent yeah yeah
yeah sorry
about that
um
but
I think getting to
do sales and ask how the weather is and
how is today and all that kind of stuff
I think get to the point hi my name's
Claire you know I specialize in placing
Senior Day scientists in health Tech
whatever it might be I think just
getting to the point have you got two
minutes to have a quick chat I think
nothing changes remembering people are
busy get to the point don't fluff
um
okay yeah sorry did you I wasn't gonna
role play but I think that's it keeping
it short sweet introducing yourself and
saying only two minutes your time at the
second one hang up on you they're gonna
hang up on you yeah and just if you can
still try and like commit to more time
to speak if they're busy Harry you got
any uh I feel like you're like I consume
a lot of content in like this as well so
I feel like there's a lot of good advice
around there I think the first the first
point is
make it warm make it warm don't don't
don't make it straight away cold because
that's the tough piece yeah right so
whether that's you send them a LinkedIn
message ahead of the the cold call or
whatever it may be or connection request
but on that conversation you always want
to make it referenceable and relatable
if you can make it those two things that
conversation is automatically going to
go better whether they know somebody
that you know whether you've done
business in a similarly ecosystem
technology whatever it may be but if you
can make it relatable and referenceable
that conversation is naturally going to
be better than hey I'm Harry from Rama
you don't know me blah blah blah like
that's really tough okay I think just
have a reason to call as well right okay
you've got everyone's LinkedIn click on
insights on the company you can see how
they've grown in the last 12 months just
even just saying that I can see you guys
have grown by like 120 the last six
months that's unreal or the event invite
or just something Google them on it's
either got crunchbase if they have a
recent investment just have a reason to
call nice uh let's do two three more
questions and we'll go there's a few
more hands Matt go to whoever you want
to
hello hello hi hi Matt next time coming
front yeah that's fine so I'm not making
any friends here hello hey I'm Georgia
from wiser Elite and my question is how
like the best way to deal with any
people that you might manage or like
junior team members that haven't been
through the hard times in recruitment
yet like a lot of us have been
recruitment a long time we've been
through the waves and like ridden the
roller coaster and that helps us to be
more mentally prepared for these times
for the people that haven't been through
it like what's the best way to deal with
them or like the advice that you would
give them
Claire I feel like you've literally been
doing this right question yeah great
question yeah yeah I think
I mean I'm fortunate now even though
it's not a huge amount of time but
we've got 18 we've been around for 18
months so for some of my newest grads
there's still people that have been
there a little bit longer so
it sounds
a bit crazy but in my head I have
you know we've got the person that
started and blanked for seven months and
is now a top Biller
and there's there's him you know his
name's Alex but and he's amazing and
he's that example of that person like
there's I remember the stories of all
the different people that have struggled
on different things and it's like in my
head of who those people are so there's
always someone to reference because I
have to remember as well it's easy for
me to talk about I've been there they
don't care that was so many years ago
I'm not in the thick of it so I always
try and figure out right who's the
person with just six months more
experience has been exactly where they
are and we're fortunate now we've got
enough people
um so it's just remembering that at the
beginning I wrote it down I wrote the
names of the different people to make
sure I didn't forget and then just
connect to them and and asking them look
do you mind taking so-and-so for a
coffee because it sometimes feels it's
going to be more powerful from me as
their leader to have that arm around the
shoulder but it's not it's way more
useful the person
that's sat next to them she's using the
yeah using their stories internally yeah
yeah yeah so I definitely hear that I
think everyone's sort of been there
where like yeah if I sat down with you
and you're like no look I've been there
then I'm like Claire [ __ ] off you've
been doing it for 10 years
exactly like you said if it's someone
six months ahead of you it's way more
relatable or kind of
remember who's who's the right people
and think strategically who's that right
person for that person because it's not
it's got to be the same it's got to be
the right story otherwise it could just
land flat to use yours yeah use internal
stories Ben Harry and the thing to add
to that
I think stop winning the Daily Mail
because yeah absolutely um I think
Claire's right it's just for me it's
just championing Champions like who are
the best people in your business right
now because they're the ones doing it
right now and just Champion those guys
as much as you can and they're your
example sessors how have you I don't
know how you have you had this
internally have you approached it yeah I
think
everyone's probably had it I think
they'd be lying if they say they haven't
but
I think Honesty comes into it you know
it's going to be a tough three to six
months if you're in Tech if you're not
maybe not but it's gonna be it's gonna
be tough right and I think the biggest
thing for me is don't deviate from the
process and strategy that you have I
think people tendent you know usually
have a tendency to want to skip out a
step because they get a little bit more
desperate with a client or they want to
negotiate a client's terms that are
slightly less or whatever it may be so I
think the biggest things right now is to
stay with the process do not deviate and
just keep you know influencing them you
know and keeping everyone you know
motivated through giving them wins when
they can Etc and trying to keep
everybody as you know as pumped as
possible at all times nice let's do one
more question at the front
and then I mean yeah well maybe two
we'll do two more questions
go over here mate that might get a bit
angry
nice
hi Molly
um hello there's gonna be a recession
there's going to be a recession
um everything's gonna happen company's
gonna die company's gonna survive and
the company's gonna Thrive so we all
want to thrive we don't want to die
so what would you do what's the one
thing you're going to do with your
business to make sure that you thrive in
that situation nice man who said there's
going to be a recession
foreign
I think like as I said I'm I just don't
believe there is going to be so
right stay positive stay positive
[Applause]
I think the minute the minute you start
thinking sorry I'm not that was a really
good question but maybe we've changed
that from recession to downturn downturn
all right can I have to think about it
can I go somewhere else okay
um double down your people so invest in
your people train your people give them
the skills to survive through whatever's
coming if it's a recession it's not a
recession look after your existing
clients like make sure you put your arm
around your existing clients and keep
hold of them and then win new business
tickets those three things for me is all
I'd be focusing on nice Harry what are
you saying I mean he works for us so I
don't know
well he's I don't know he might not have
asked you that in the office
well what do you think Ollie
all right ah all right uh Claire have
you got anything my three options no
it's up to you so like what's what would
like what are you gonna focus on so you
thrive rather than I think it's just not
panicking not changing strategy too much
and
okay just yeah just
yeah downtown is going to be tough but
we don't need to change markets we don't
need to change the way we need to get
better how we recruit but just keep
doing what you're doing because
keep them changing things that doesn't
work just keep focusing and we're all
good recruiters everyone works I assume
for good companies like it will be fine
okay
uh let's do one more question Matt if
that's okay
sorry not everyone's gonna be able to
ask a question sorry
hey I'm Liv I work at benetrix my
question to you guys is I'm in my first
year in recruitment so if you guys could
give your younger selves a top tip for
when you first start out what would it
be nice
nice
[ __ ] hell who was Harry what are you
saying let's go there we'll go you mate
okay what would I do what would the the
yeah top advice be to your younger self
I think for me it was when I just
related to myself when I first started
out in the first year it was
um
there's a couple of things I think
firstly it was I would literally speak
to anybody and everybody and I would try
and create as much of a brand as I
possibly could and you later find out
you wasted your time with a lot of
people but you actually then learned
who's good and who's not and who are the
right companies to be targeting and who
aren't
um but I think characteristic wise
obsession is the most important thing
for me that I found is you've got to be
obsessed with your Market you've got to
be obsessed with your clients you've got
to be obsessed with your business your
brand and how you operate be obsessed
with the process and honestly just keep
going because on my first year was
[ __ ] hard and you know I think
there's so many times in the first year
recruitment you want to quit so many
times over but if you keep going it will
turn good at some point if you follow
the right process and you have the right
people around you
of a pen
um I think first of all make sure you're
working for the best guy I love the
networks I love you on the socials very
good big fan
um but I think make sure you're working
for the right companies you've got a
good vehicle that allows you to achieve
your goals so for me having a company
that gives you Equity or the best
training or surrounding yourself by the
best people in the industry so you can
learn I think it's super super important
um I think how his words absolutely
you're going to have the shittest times
like you're gonna have the worst times
but just stick with it because we're all
set up here not doing badly I don't
think earnings wise
um so you just stick with it and you
will get there you'll have a great
career it's one of the funnest jobs I
feel very lucky to say I love this
industry so [ __ ] much it's one of the
funnest jobs you'll ever do great career
progression great earnings just stick at
it
um Matt Matt let's do one more we'll do
one more question
I'm sorry I'm sorry no because I was
thinking about my answer
what to live with yeah what I was
actually going to say okay as a female
you're a female I'm a female
good observation yeah just make sure
yeah okay but I I my I think I get asked
this question quite a lot and I think
it's an important answer like as when I
started as a grad as a female in let's
face it recruitment is still male
dominated yeah you're up with three guys
mate at senior level it is it still is
and women are some of the best
recruiters I think you'll find there you
go but it is like let's not dance around
the subject the majority of
CEOs leaders Founders in recruitment
they are still men yeah and
stand up who is that no but I think if I
could talk to a 21 year old Claire it's
like it's not a man's world like and you
can progress as a female when I joined I
didn't see any females seeing a females
didn't see any pregnant females
certainly not and it's a six week Role
Model A seek Role Models seek role
models and don't think well just because
you know and there's there are some
companies that have a loads of females
right but let's face it that's not the
relative industry but I I think don't
have limited beliefs because
yeah nice
right let's do uh we'll do one more
question Matt that's all right sorry
we'll just do one more as Joe Joe's very
Joe come down Joe's gonna get angry
Joe it better be a good it better be a
good question
I know this is like the pressure's on
I've been strong now pressures on that
come on I'm Joe I'm director ion search
Global Rector rack
the flex
um I suppose this is more focused at
ucire but it's a a panel question you've
had well storm in general has had a defo
a different found in the most
recruitment companies and you're now the
new
grad Factory as such like these behaves
and Page the level that you're hiring is
insane so what's more important to you
now headcount or Revenue because of the
backing that you've got
and the context is you you guys have
been backed by VC right is it yeah okay
so we you know we're very fortunate to
to launch with investment right a lot of
companies wait a certain amount of years
get the first of my investment we we
raise money at the outset to allow us to
grow so quickly I think what's important
now is
it's not just head count growth for her
head count growth stage I think we've
done a lot of the head count growth
we've got a lot of the good people it's
now investing in them and developing
them I don't we're not going to be doing
the crazy crazy numbers that you've seen
in previous years next year it's going
to be steady it's going to be growth
still going to be high I don't think
we're going to be doing 25 people at a
time it'll be 15 and it's all about yeah
investing in the the growth and the
people that we've hired so far okay
there we go Joe thank you I love how
we're a factory yes
no yeah yeah hey it's mental
um well let's have a round of applause
for the Ben eclair and Harry
yeah
there we go
um thanks everyone feel free to stay for
a little bit longer but thank you so
much for coming and thank you thank you
[Applause]